moving on i have a
study i prepared
okay awesome so i'm gonna start with
like a composition chest thing
let's go with this one
oh is it good on stream can they see the
board yeah yeah awesome so this is a
composition puzzle checkmate in two
moves
so why still move obviously this is a
you know position that as white you
would you know win easily in like 10 15
moves maybe or six five whatever uh but
this is now
about a very specific variation that you
need to find because it's forced
checkmate in two
and i know that some players dislike
solving puzzles like this i used to be
that kind of player i still dislike
solving puzzles where they're like eight
queens on the board and it's like
ridiculous but i actually really enjoy
solving composition chess
because i feel it uh really helps you to
be precise and sometimes there is a
moment in the game where you have to be
super super precise
and it helps you to understand how
pieces cooperate together
so first suggestion yeah queen h4
if let's say the king moves here rook g
rook g4 checkmate
yep the thing is after queen h4
king g1
and oh you're so nice thank you
and after um rogue g4 then we are
blocking it with bishop g2
so and by the way one thing i
i would like all of you not to use any
um any computers nothing just try to
find it yourself and if you don't see
the solution just come up with your idea
so i know what you are thinking and we
can and i can kind of guide you
uh to the direction
give you direction sorry
i'm gonna be a little bit quiet
to give you time to think on tv
there
that's so funny
all right you found mount
checkmate in four so now just
just you know cut down do it in half
by the way this pawn is going this way
i um i studied at webster university at
susan polgar
uh
what is it institute of excellence and
it was so fun because i was you know
taking
uh i was at the team with like uh rare
ups and eleanor's [ __ ] like mongolia
i'm like the top you know grandmasters
in the world
and when we were
analyzing any games together on like a
screen
uh susan would very often not have the
notation there and it would be very
annoying for me i don't need the
notation there just like mentally
so when she was so once i asked like if
she can have the notation there and she
felt like she was like looking at me
like are you serious you're a
grandmaster and i was like no i really
want that and she thought it was a joke
so then i started to ask anytime she
like put a puzzle there i was like okay
which way this pawn goes which way that
pawn goes and since that whenever we
were practicing at webster there was
always notation on the board
so
i feel like i made a difference
yeah it's checkmate in two moves
and it is a composition puzzle so this
never happened somebody composed it and
i know who that somebody is i just have
it
um
uh somewhere down i would need to like
scroll down um
and it is a challenging thing so we
thought about queen h4 that doesn't work
so i want you to kind of think with
other moves and
tell me if you see they don't work what
is the reason because that's really the
goal you need to kind of listen to your
intuition go with the moves that your
brain is suggesting and then figure out
what is the reason why it doesn't work
and that will guide you further
so i need someone to tell me what's the
key issue why we can kind of succeed in
the checkmates
that we want
yeah so k2 could be also a nice idea but
bishop d2 is blocking it
so what else
if v4 is here we are saying also the
bishop blocks it afterwards yeah the
bishop covers a lot of stuff exactly so
anytime the king can kind of go and try
to hide
okay so
it matters which way dupont goes but
it's still fine but i have a i don't see
you but i have a question can before you
tell the solution can you tell us how
you discover it like what is the main
kind of issue
okay so i think you tell me do peace you
want to play with the move
rook okay so i will i will ask you to
say the move in a second
before you say that the thing i realized
is when i was looking at this position
is that
i don't see a checkmate anytime the
bishop makes one of those moves
something so i realize that if
like the bishop let's say goes here and
now i have two moves to make a checkmate
that kind of helped me to realize where
i need to have my pieces so when i make
a move they move the bishop somewhere i
can checkmate so what is the move
very good
rook ivan this is like crazy move again
like just think about it moves this move
will not cross your mind unless you
realize that kind of this bishop yeah it
can block everything but when the bishop
moves it kind of clears some squares so
let's see so first of all if the king
moves
there's queen
quindy to checkmate
so nowhere to go
um now if they make let's say with the
bishop here or anywhere on this diagonal
we have this really cool move cringy one
so these pieces are cooperating together
and if they go anywhere well if they go
here
we have the same queen g1
and if they go here
queen h4
very good
so i think again like
it's very easy to spend like 20 you know
20 minutes on this puzzle but i feel
like when you find it it starts like
your understanding of the pieces the
position i think it's really helpful to
try to solve sometimes composition
composition chest because it i think it
does help you in your actual chest
so okay i have normal puzzles that we
can go after but let's continue with
composition chess all right three move
checkmate here
so this didn't appear and again this did
not occur in the game yeah
just a clarification so white to move
checkmate in three moves
and again you could say oh you know this
is stupid obviously i can win this in
you know more moves but again how like
it's very simple looking is so close to
white's camp so how to like how to
coordinate your pieces so quickly
that's funny
yeah imagine you are black and if black
survives three moves black wins
and again i first recommend to kind of
follow your intuition what moves your
brain is suggesting go with them and
then figure out why it doesn't work and
one clarification black is not gonna
help you
like i remember showing this puzzle to a
student and like she thought that black
is gonna cooperate like no if black can
defend they will do everything in their
power not to get checkmated
all right so we have uh b carries
suggesting d4 do we approve
okay we have approval for d4 so d4 is
the first move so we are kind of
creating a first
small wall for the king let's say i want
to escape
queen d3 now we create actual real wall
to stop the king from moving let's say i
go here
yep very good now queen h3 checkmate
now when we go back
again d4 black car can hardly play
something different because queen g4
we do the same thing we go here
stopping the king from going anywhere
actually no sorry uh that was not the
variation after king h5 king d3 now if
not king g4 but king h4
we go the same thing
king h3
uh
but now the question is what to do after
king g4
so now you have two moves to checkmate
okay e4 and if i move here
very good g3 so now e4 there we are
stopping this uh stopping uh king two
going to this square and we have this
wall so has to go here and now g3 yep
good job imani too
was there you said there was a second
wave
or was that
no i think this is the only one
yeah okay moving on
oh this is one of my this is a yeah i
really like this position all right
this is much easier people only in two
moves
white to checkmate in two moves
i remember solving this and really
took some time
so first we want to go with like the
most logical moves right like if i go
let's say rook g3
okay they're gonna probably block no
checkmate
another one queen g3
they're gonna block
and i don't think we have a move in one
checkmate
so try to go with the most logical one
and then see
how is black always defending and maybe
you see a theme
and then i'm gonna
guide you next
checkmate in two move
okay before you
i know that you're not suggesting move
in chat but before you suggest the moves
i actually want you to tell me the first
move you would play not by telling me
the move but telling me the idea what
are you accomplishing
like what is the problem
that you are trying to kind of fix
nope not accepting any moves i want only
verbal answers
yeah this is checkmate in two moves
so i want to hear the ideas because
let's say people can solve it i want to
help to guide them i just don't want to
like you know give them the solution
that's that's not going to improve their
understanding how to solve these puzzles
in the future
because i i can tell my specific kind of
train of thought when i was solving this
okay need something that stops bishop g4
and bishop g6 if that's the checkmate
you want to do okay
okay i have i have queens to access too
many squares so one thing i was looking
realizing this and this doesn't work
i was looking at moves like queen f4 and
queen f2 with the idea to checkmate here
or here
or kind of here the problem was what i
realized is that if i go queen f4 or
queen f2 either of those moves the king
is going to run here to g6 and from g6
i'm not going to checkmate the king
there because the king can hide there
so i was looking at here okay goes there
no checkmate
uh
goes here again runs away here so i was
like all right so i'm getting the idea
that if i cover g6
uh then i'm gonna check made the king so
the only really way to cover g6 is queen
c2 so i was like all right cool job
queen c2
and
wait i hear myself back i hate that
um when i but then i realized if i play
queen c2 which is the only move to cover
the g6 square what is black gonna do
bishop g4 exactly so good job your queen
is covering g6 but after bishop g4
you don't have a checkmate
so
i was like too bad but
king g6
uh yeah exactly good job manny
so i realized that king g6 is gonna
happen i can't stop it
so my thinking was in a very similar way
to uh if i just switch for a second to
this position when i was looking at how
i'm gonna checkmate if the bishop is not
on f1 and we thought it you know rook e1
and this is gonna checkmate so the same
way i was looking here and i was like
okay how do i checkmate the king when
the king is on g7 g6
and when i figure out how i'm going to
check my looking when the king is on g6
i know the solution to this puzzle
so let's see if i was able to help you
okay many things he got it we have one
person here who got it or two
one okay
so you just need to answer a question if
we have
this king right there where do you need
one of your pieces to be to check by the
king
what about people online
how are we gonna check made the king if
the king is on g6
yep
very good so
let's see what here in person what is
the solution
very good so the solution is queen a2
because after king g6 the queen can go
here and checkmate which is like really
hard checkmate to find like it's like
crazy it's the almost longest distance
you can travel on the board in two moves
uh
but that's it and now if obviously they
don't have to go there if they don't
want but if they go bishop g4
we are still gonna checkmate them from
here
if they gonna go here
we can go back and checkmate here and if
they go
sorry that's not if they go here then we
are also going back
and checkmating
so
kind of again two move checkmate could
be
uh
could be very easy in some puzzles you
know just check and checkmate but in
composition chess it requires really
kind of
niche understanding about what's
happening
and since we are doing such a good job
let's move on
checkmate in two moves
white to move
yep i'm happy you like it i really like
these puzzles
they also force you to be like 100
focused
i don't think it's about like dude i
think it's about like
um
like kind of eliminating options
because like the the solution to the
to these puzzles you are not gonna most
likely you are not gonna find or on your
first try but it's like you're gonna try
to go with the ideas that you have in
your head and suddenly none of them will
gonna work so you're gonna figure out
what's the issue with the position and
then you will find this like you know
move that solves everything
okay we have one person who has the
solution don't don't say the solution
please in chat
but
you can
give like a verbal
so queen h3 if you go queen h3
i like your idea maybe but this is not a
checkmate so after queen h3 i think i
can push the pawn
and now you have only one move to
checkmate and since this is not a
checkmate i still can escape
it's not gonna work
i mean first move we have to consider
all of us queen takes right so queen
takes
now if the king goes here
we are checkmating
yep good job
but black is not gonna help us so if we
take the king goes here
and now
the rook is hanging
the king can always go back
so even if we go queen there
the king now is escaping here and it's
not a checkmate
so queen takes king here
and now we have one move to checkmate
and there's just no move
so okay we eliminate this move
i think eliminating stuff is really
important so if we go here it just
doesn't work
so let's you know
let's come up with another variation
that does not work
yep i found somebody i agree for example
if we move the rook somewhere in here to
just like waste time this is actually a
stalemate because the
queen is guarding this knight is
guarding this and the rook the rest of
it
so we cannot just like you know do
nothing
or like i don't move the king here
because it's a stalemate
we probably cannot give a check because
then the king escapes and has another
many squares to go to
yes
so what what else
so you see like we are starting to like
suddenly run out of options
let's say we move the knight here the
king moves here
knight is attacked king has extra square
not gonna work
so suddenly the options are kind of
shrinking
and we need to become a little more
creative
and open to possibilities
so i'm waiting for somebody in chat to
or here
don't see
i mean this is hard like please
i don't want anybody to feel like
ashamed like oh i can find a checkmate
in two moves this is really hard
uh
but i really think it's important i
started to write a book about uh
blindfold chess
and like the more i read research about
it like
the way like how we understand pieces
and how they cooperate it's really super
important and relevant to our chest
strength
so
these puzzles help us to understand how
pieces cooperate together
oh queen f5 is a nice idea to bring the
queen closer but i think queen f5 i have
to push the pawn
and it
yeah
and it's not not working exactly as you
are saying
so no use of engines please please
promise
but if anyone sees it or please in chat
like if you see a variation that doesn't
work or an idea that doesn't work or if
you have like
something to chip in so i'm it's not
just me talking
i'll be very happy to read it and then
i remember me solving this position i
also couldn't believe it that i just
can't see it so i was just like let's
just like stare at the position and just
let the creativity kind of roll like me
like i'm just watching like a painting
or something and get ideas how
checkmates can appear and then out of
nowhere i just okay i got it
so try to like force it less and just
like really be creative to see how
checkmates
like what are the options
found it someone no i just
uh-huh you're encouraging us to say
yeah
yeah so if we move the knight the king
very quickly moved to e7 and i don't
think we can ever check midoking there
in one move
right
yeah okay that would
that that's actually true that would
work because then go but that doesn't
work but if that doesn't work knight f4
then like anywhere we move the knight
then like this is always like creating
more options and the backward square
so i think
me personally we can eliminate a move
with the knight
right so you can even go with
eliminating moves or pieces
okay suggesting knight c7 knight c7 is
also another like nice idea to bring the
queen there but the king can just escape
yeah but i'm very happy you're keeping
up the communication now open and
suggesting stuff and yes casual player
this is checkmate in two moves
um first move is with king i could be
so king f so if we move there it's a
stella mate if we move anywhere backward
we're gonna just lose that knight and
nothing so what king f5
it's crazy i see everyone like oh wow
like i'm gonna it's really hard please
don't feel like it's crazy so so let's
see the checkmate what's gonna happen if
they take the night
you did it right
go for it you can do it we are all
rooting for you
yep i see the chat is just like you can
do it you can do it
uh so it's here
here and queen d1 i mean this is such a
hard checkmate to see
because like we don't think about queen
moving backward
but i think it's like really cool and
again this is like it helps us to like
you know the pieces how they cooperate
and it go here and go there
yeah it's kinky five discovered
i know like see thinking about move like
king f5 is definitely hard like no like
seriously this is hard and i think it
also comes with um
with like practice like the more you do
composition chest the more like open you
are to king moves or stuff like that uh
but it's just key to i think finding
this first checkmate is just really like
we just do i think many of us consider
first king of five king takes and then
we are like this is not a checkmate and
nothing this is just too far
or queen c4 correct we just like sing
back seeing backwater moves is really
really hard i know there's this book
it's called invisible moves
it's really cool book and it just shows
how like move backwards or night
backwards are really easy to miss
okay
oh you did yeah it's a really cool book
i mean the only reason that we've
occurred it seemed like we eliminated
all the other pieces and then that was
the one
that's another thing okay i'm gonna go
back for a second that's another thing
like but there's nothing wrong with the
elimination because i also think
sometimes in chats when we are
calculating a line we are like you know
it doesn't work with the queen doesn't
work with a ch with the rope and then we
like track the line and sometimes we
don't go like oh maybe we could work
with the knight so i still feel like you
know the elimination stuff is like just
getting into that process is good all
right you guys are doing amazingly so i
have one more prepared for you
now see we are kind of graduating to
checkmate in three
take me into what's too easy for you
so check mate in three and again please
let's go with like uh some you know i
put these puzzles to my students very uh
no it's in three sorry checkmating three
uh i put these puzzles to my students
very uh very often especially if they
already have like good skills but the
problem is after like few lessons they
suddenly be like all right let's move
like queen f1 like the most like stupid
move they start to suggest and i was
like no no let's go with the most
natural like this should be the first
move to control this probably this
should be probably it's not correct
right it's too easy but find the reason
why it does not work because that will
guide you if you start to think with
moves like i don't know here that's
actually illegal
don't think about moves like that
exactly
i'm sorry
okay so
yeah so go with some like ideas
and figure out why they don't work
so white to move checkmate in three
moves
so let's go like this
only move
i don't know check here
moves there check escapes survives right
so this probably doesn't work
go here
only move
check
goes here survives
so just looking at these two variations
again let's say one more check here
cannot go there because this is a
checkmate
so go here go there
uh go here survive so we are getting the
idea of this king here
is kind of surviving very often here so
one thing to consider yeah queen c4 not
to allow the checkmate
so what's gonna happen after queen c4
because if queen c4 works good done
so suggesting queen c4
yeah bishop b3 even
both i think those move bishop b3 bishop
a4
uh
i don't see a checkmate after that
because here here
yeah maybe any bishop move actually not
any because if we go here they go there
we can checkmate this way but any bishop
move on that diagonal i think it's gonna
save us
because then if we go check they're
escaping
so
we did not
solve the situation but now we should
get another idea with
uh that should guide us more what is the
thing what did we figure out about the
king a6 movement
idea so we are clearing this
so
let's say i've yeah
let's say i give check
king back let's say i go back
oh no then you are checkmating me okay
so
takes takes back
here
oh yeah
queen b3
could be but
maybe
maybe not
but it's better move than my suggestion
it's still better
no
so
no i want to hear what did we learn
about the move king a6
king a6 about it i mean
we see that like the thing is escaping
there right so we start we try to stop
it like in c4 which doesn't work so what
does it lead us to do probably the thing
is kinetics we just like i've been
trying to make stuff like queen d at
work because the candy 6.8 is made
okay so
yeah but um
uh so
your yearly joe suggested earlier like
queen f1 was something i was looking at
and then i realized
because it actually it looks like me too
right because if you go
bishop a4 or something uh-huh i think
queen f8 i
think it's just me no i still go there
oh wait no never mind but
okay
or just escapes anyway uh-huh so
yeah but i think what we realize now is
that
kind of similar again to the puzzle
remember when the things were there
yeah exactly what
myc is saying like king a6 is gonna
happen
so your next step be like okay how do i
where do i want to have my pieces and
how am i gonna checkmate the king when
it gets to a6
so yeah one of the idea is to go to
kingd queen d8
so if it wants to go there good job i'm
going to check my tube all right so if
we go there
what is another solution so another
option is
what if i
run
so i feel like if they run
they are surviving
yeah
by the way let's say we pass okay we
play we pass the king runs here how are
we gonna checkmate do we have checkmate
in two moves
oh gm robson is here
right how quickly do you see the
solution i give you one minute
uh how are we gonna check me the king
now if king white pass
made a pass and king a4
how do we check made in two
do we have a check market too
there is a check meeting too
so let's
it's very tricky but it's important to
see that kind of checkmate
i talking about wait what
yeah
i was like queen you said like queen c3
no never mind it doesn't work i was like
wait what that's my solution yeah so
here's queen c3 and checkmate here
right so
that's just interesting to know how we
can checkmate here okay
so yeah so let's let's come up so queen
da doesn't work good idea doesn't work
because the king can run and suddenly we
can't check mate
so don't tell me the solution again tell
us
give us a clue what did you realize like
what just struck you so the exact same
idea
that we have
with queen c3 exists on the other part
of the board like the problem with candy
sticks and candy corn is the same
problem so
okay so i don't know if if the mic picks
up on you but he's saying that uh
he wants to do something similar on like
the way we check right here on the other
side okay we are getting idea queen h3
so queen h3 if i
uh let's say you move bishop
here not sorry here
how are you going to check made me in
two moves now
because if you go there
c8 i'm gonna go there
so i'm gonna like block if i can
so queen actually is the good idea i
remember it was one of the most i
considered as well
but it doesn't work
but yeah there is something about
okay i want someone else from chat maybe
making one more suggestion or here and
then we're gonna look at the
solution because yeah this is brutal and
i think it took me also like oh you have
it i many wow
okay
or do i i don't know
but these puzzles like if anyone maybe i
can like
put um
oh i have another lychee study with few
of those puzzles so i can share them
with you if anyone is interested to just
suffer for a little longer than is
necessary
but okay so what is the solution
yep yeah so queen g3 here i think is
correct because if p96 and queen c7
then you can't stop v6 and if you go
um
k84 then we can see that you still
need very good job both in class in
online queen g3 is the solution so we
are keeping the queen on this third rank
so anytime the king moves here we can
always recover to go c3 and checkmate
here
now if the king wants to escape to a6
then we want to capture this pawn and
checkmate here
and
what else can we oh and there's one more
thing actually what if after this move
they're going to play
[Music]
well okay
but if you go if you go towards the king
side of the queen a3 and if
yeah so they're just like i can go back
here to try to check my door i can go
here and here to check mine
oh okay yeah so what are we going to do
actually this is key this is also
important
this bishop s3 what are we going to do
after that
oh yeah that's actually one last
important line but when you feel like
queen g3 is the move because it works in
most of the line now you just need to
find the last kind of variation
so now checkmate in two
easy peasy
uh
yeah it's just straight with check three
we need one
if you take on c7
the king is going to escape
yep
g8 like this is just like such an
incredible move oh
because we want to checkmate here
and if you want to run this way i want
to check my view here
i feel like this puzzle is like yoga you
know it forces you to like stretch like
calculate like see the queen like
backward forward like it's just
yeah but such a cool move i think queen
g3 this is a nice defensive move that
forces you to find this last move kind
of this
and checkmate but i feel like for me the
key situation was to figure out how am i
going to yeah exactly obviously queen g8
how am i going to check made when the
king moves here because when i found it
after king a6 i have kind of this
checkmate then i felt like in g3 we are
on the right track
and um
and we just need to figure out like how
to you know put those puzzles into place
in other situations
yeah i think this is this is really
really cool
so
i hope you are a little impressed wait
after queen g3 bishop b3 yeah
yeah we still go queen c7 because if you
go here i now can check my view this way
the bishop is kind of blocking your way
out unfortunately and if you go here we
still get the same checkmate
would that be considered
that's kind of
kind of double agent bishop now yep
absolutely
um
yeah so this is really nice so i
uh if any of you are interested
uh yeah but i i would need to log in
from logout from sentence well i guess
next time lecture i can give you the
link or
on my on my personal account katrina
nemco i can make the
study private i mean public actually so
you can access it if you want but i
highly recommend to you know to do this
composition such as
uh you can find them even online there
is this book on amazon
i remember when i wanted to buy it it
was for like 300 because i guess no one
had it and it was just like this thin
paper book but i think it went back uh
it got reprinted and it was known like a
few bucks
now it's like you know 5 30 or something
it's really like just printed pages like
it's not even like hard
yeah i mean i have all the
so i have the whole book because i
i i mean i do a lot of composition chess
there is one book called like
1 000
no 100 uh studies and i saw that when i
was like younger so then my coach gave
me another one which was like
composition chess but it was two three
four and five checkmate
but like you know checkmate in four when
it's like really crazy that's
i think i oh that was like too much for
me but i did two three and i tried four
sometimes but that would be sometimes
like three queens and four ropes like
it's it's too much yeah
but
yeah i mean i don't think that this
helps you to like obviously in normal
chess you can you know solve you can win
with extra queen little little sooner or
i even hate when like you you do online
puzzles and you can you know you you
have a solution to a puzzle like you win
a queen and then you know chess.com on
leeches is like incorrect because
instead of taking the queen you should
have checkmated in two and i'm like well
i'm gonna win with that queen anyway so
i get really mad
but so this is not like to force doing
the fastest way but i think it really
helps you to see how pieces cooperate
together and like how you know queen how
powerful they are like to do what can
they can do and and stuff like that
awesome that's all from me thank you so
much for hanging around it was fun i
hope you are enjoying composition chest
now
i hope you don't get a headache from
that so take a break and see you next
time bye everyone